find the slope of a line perpendicular
to the line 3x plus 2y is equal to 6. so
if i have one line let me draw some
quick axis here so that's my y-axis and
that is my x-axis and let's say i have a
line here that has a slope of m so the
slope over here is equal to m
a line whose a line that is
perpendicular this line would intersect
it at 90 degrees so it would look
something like this it would look
something like this this would be a 90
degree angle and the slope here and i
won't prove it in this video we talk
about it in other videos the slope here
is going to be equal to the negative
reciprocal of this line slope so it's
going to be the negative
reciprocal of that slope so order of the
way it's going to be it's going to be
negative 1 over the slope or the
negative reciprocal now with that out of
the way if we could figure out the slope
of this line right over here we would
just have to take the negative
reciprocal and we would have the slope
of the perpendicular line so let's
figure out the slope of this line so let
me rewrite it 3x plus 2y
is equal to 6. and the easiest thing to
do is to solve for y so we get into y
equals mx plus b form and then the slope
will be pretty obvious so let's get rid
of the x on the left-hand side so let's
subtract x 3x from both sides i should
say
and then the left hand side we're left
with just a 2y the right hand side we
have a negative 3x
plus 6. now we can divide both sides by
2 so we have to divide all the terms on
the right hand side by 2.
we get y is equal to negative 3 halves x
that's that part right over there plus
3. so the slope of this line right over
here that they give us the slope of this
line now that we've put it in mx plus b
form slope intercept form we know that
the slope of this line is negative three
halves that is the slope so the slope of
a line that is perpendicular to this
will be the negative reciprocal of this
so the negative of a negative is a
positive so it's going to be a positive
and then the reciprocal of three halves
is going to be two
over three
so the negative reciprocal of three of
negative three halves is positive two
over three so that's we're done that's
the slope of a line that is
perpendicular to this one right over
here